What is an algorithm? What would you say an algorithm is? What is an algorithm? It's like a set of operations, a routine procedure for calculating something. Yeah, so that's the definition that they give here. They give it as a way to do things. And it's an interesting definition here where he defines it as an algorithm is like a set of steps that you can follow with pen and paper. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 218, recorded on January 22nd, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about a book that he recently purchased in London called Algorithms. You've got fake snow behind you, but there's also, I imagine, real snow.
什么是算法？你会怎么定义算法？什么是算法？它就像是一系列操作，一种用于计算某事物的常规程序。是的，这就是他们在这里给出的定义。他们将其定义为一种做事的方式。这里的定义很有趣，他将算法定义为一种可以用纸笔遵循的步骤集合。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 218 期，录制于 2025 年 1 月 22 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将聊聊他最近在伦敦买的一本书，书名就叫《算法》。你身后有假雪，但我猜外面也有真雪。
It is minus 14, feels like minus 21. Let's get that in Fahrenheit for you folks. Now even I know that that's minus 6 Fahrenheit. Yeah, that is rough. That is an extreme cold warning in Toronto.
气温是零下 14 度，体感零下 21 度。给听众朋友们换算成华氏度，连我都记得那是华氏零下 6 度。是的，这太糟糕了。多伦多发布了极寒预警。
Yeah. Yeah, it's extreme cold warning in Toronto. Yeah. Yeah, it's pretty cold here. Funny thing. So I think, yeah, so I spent a few years living in Louisiana when I worked at LSU. And I remember one time there was like a frost at LSU. It was like February or something. And there was, you know was going to be frost and maybe some ice. And they shut down the university for like two days because there was a concern that there could be black ice on some of the stairs and that the LSU students wouldn't know
是的。是的，多伦多发布了极寒预警。是的。是的，这里非常冷。有趣的是，我想，是的，我在路易斯安那州工作时在那里住了几年，当时是在路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）。我记得有一次 LSU 出现了霜冻，大概是二月份左右。当时预报会有霜冻，可能还有冰。他们让大学停课了两天，因为担心楼梯上可能会有黑冰，而且 LSU 的学生可能不知道
how to handle that. And so, it was just best just to shut down the whole place. And I don't know if they actually got 11 inches, but Louisiana has been hit with like a ton of snow. They have like, I think like eight inches in New Orleans. And New Orleans, folks, New Orleans has eight inches of snow. Like, what is this weird world we live in right now? Oh, man. But I just, I'm thinking about my old boss Hartmut who, he really, you know, one of the main reasons he moved to Louisiana was the weather. Like he doesn't want to be cold. He likes that it's nice and warm there. Maybe it gets a little too warm, but I'm just thinking like the last day, like last day like god that poor guy like i you know
该如何应对。所以，把整个地方关掉是最好的选择。我不知道他们是否真的积雪达到了 11 英寸，但路易斯安那州确实遭遇了大量的降雪。我想新奥尔良大概有 8 英寸的积雪。新奥尔良，朋友们，新奥尔良有 8 英寸的雪。天哪，我们现在生活在一个什么样的奇怪世界里？哦，天哪。但我只是在想我的老上司 Hartmut，他搬到路易斯安那州的主要原因之一就是天气。他不想挨冻。他喜欢那里温暖舒适。也许那里有点太热了，但我只是在想，最后一天，天哪，那个可怜的家伙，我，你知道
i don't even know if he owns anything other than shorts anymore and uh and it's got to be brutal there thoughts go out to those in louisiana and anywhere warm that is not i mean it's pretty cold for toronto but uh it's not atypical that once or twice a year it drops down this low. So you said it is negative 11 here Celsius, and it feels like, well, it says it feels like that, but I think it feels like negative 14. I think it feels closer to negative 20. Yeah, I mean, I haven't gone outside yet today, but I try to minimize. I'm hoping I won't have to. Yeah.
我甚至不知道他除了短裤还有没有别的衣服，而且那里一定很残酷。向路易斯安那州和任何温暖的地方的人们致以慰问，我的意思是，对多伦多来说这很冷，但一年中气温降到这么低一两次并不罕见。所以你说这里是摄氏零下 11 度，体感，嗯，上面写的是体感温度，但我认为体感是零下 14 度。我觉得体感更接近零下 20 度。是的，我的意思是，我今天还没出门，但我尽量减少外出。我希望我不需要出门。是的。
Yeah, in the last couple of days, trying to stay indoors is a good play. Just go to the gym. Don't run outside these days. Yeah. I don't even have to go far to the gym. It's just I have the Bowflex Max trainer right there. Looks like a Transformers robot or whatever you call those things. It's really good when I'm not lazy. So how have you been?
是的，过去几天，尽量待在室内是个好主意。去健身房就行。这些天别在外面跑步。是的。我甚至不需要走远去健身房。我就在那儿放着 Bowflex Max 训练器。看起来像个变形金刚机器人或者你管那叫什么东西。当我没那么懒的时候，它真的很好用。那么你最近怎么样？
I've been good. How about you? 2025? 2025. New year. New year. Yeah, I'm good. Been busy at work i've actually well you're gonna you're gonna be shocked the listeners gonna be shocked i have not one but two programming books that are like here that i've been reading this morning one of them is just called i want to say that's programming pearls but i can't actually read it because it's white text on beige um it's this one is just called algorithms this one i i i texted you about this like i got this in november when i was on the way back i want to say it was like a month or two
我很好。你呢？2025 年？2025 年。新年。新年。是的，我很好。工作很忙，实际上，嗯，你会感到震惊的，听众们也会感到震惊，我今天早上读了两本编程书，就在这儿。其中一本我想说是《编程珠玑》，但我实际上读不出来，因为它是米色背景上的白色文字，嗯，这一本就叫《算法》，这一本，我给你发过短信，我是在十一月回来的路上买的，我想大概是一两个月
ago yeah but then this is just um elements programming. Oh, elements of programming. It has a very yellow cover, and then it has silver text on the yellow cover. I'm not sure that I agree with that cover design. But yeah, I've been reading them. And some interesting things. Some interesting things. Share with us the interesting things that have been accumulated from these two books link oh in the show notes folks perfect we don't have affiliate links if you click on them you're i mean eop is for free so yeah not if you want this copy this
前，是的，然后这一本只是《编程要素》。哦，《编程要素》。它有一个非常黄的封面，封面上是银色的文字。我不确定我是否认同那个封面设计。但是的，我一直在读它们。还有一些有趣的事情。一些有趣的事情。和我们分享一下从这两本书中积累的有趣事情吧，链接在节目说明里，朋友们，完美。我们没有联盟链接，如果你点击它们，我的意思是《编程要素》是免费的，所以是的，如果你想要这本副本，这个
ironically speaking of hartman kaiser this this book was given to me by my mentor, my guru, Hartmut Kaiser, for my must have been 20th birthday. It was the first birthday that I was there in Louisiana. And he just came up to my desk and he gave it to me and he said, here, happy birthday. And that is how I acquired my hard copy of Elements of Programming. It wasn't wrapped or anything. It was just here. You need this. is how I acquired my hard copy of Elements of Programming. It wasn't wrapped or anything. It was just here. You need this.
讽刺的是，说到 Hartmut Kaiser，这本书是我在 20 岁生日时，我的导师、我的大师 Hartmut Kaiser 送给我的。那是我在路易斯安那州度过的第一个生日。他走到我的办公桌前，把它给了我，说：“给你，生日快乐。”这就是我获得《编程要素》实体书的方式。它没有包装，什么都没有。它只是在那儿。你需要这个。这就是我获得《编程要素》实体书的方式。它没有包装，什么都没有。它只是在那儿。你需要这个。
So this is that copy? You made it sound like you picked up both of these books for the last couple of months. No, no, no, this is that copy. I think that it is very hard to get this copy of EOP. I do not think that this has been in print for some long period of time yeah i think that this has not been in print for a while all right so one book recently acquired another book anciently yes yes i think this is also a first edition yes it does appear to be a first edition one of my many randomly valuable uh programming. So I opened up the other book to the exact page that I wanted.
所以这是那一本？你听起来好像是过去几个月才买的这两本书。不，不，不，这就是那一本。我认为很难买到这本《编程要素》。我不认为它已经印刷很长时间了，是的，我想它已经有一段时间没再版了。好吧，所以一本书是最近买的，另一本书是很久以前买的。是的，是的，我想这也是第一版。是的，它看起来确实是第一版，是我许多随机且有价值的编程书籍之一。所以我把另一本书翻到了我想要的那一页。
So this book, it's called Algorithms. I got it at, I went to this, we had like an eight-hour layover in London. And so my girlfriend, Ramona, not liking to just spend time in airports waiting. She was like, let's go into the city and do something. And so we went into this little – Was this Heathrow? Yeah, this was Heathrow. We went into this little museum in, I think it was Hyde Park.
所以这本书，它叫《算法》。我是在伦敦有八小时中转时买的。所以我的女朋友 Ramona 不喜欢在机场等待。她说：“我们进城做点什么吧。”所以我们去了这个小——这是希思罗机场吗？是的，这是希思罗机场。我们去了这个小博物馆，我想是在海德公园。
Let me go to – let me go find London here on Google Maps. Yeah, it was Hyde Park, and there's this little museum called the Serpentine Gallery. And they had this exhibit on artificial intelligence, of course. They had this music that was composed by various neural nets. It was just like a small exhibit. It took like 15, 20 minutes to go through it. But then they had a bookshop and I had both Ramona and my mother with me. And so, of course, we had to spend as much time in the museum bookshop because they both love a good museum bookshop.
让我去——让我去谷歌地图上找找伦敦。是的，那是海德公园，有一个叫蛇形画廊的小博物馆。当然，他们有一个关于人工智能的展览。他们有各种神经网络创作的音乐。这只是一个小展览。逛完大概花了 15 到 20 分钟。但后来他们有一个书店，我带着 Ramona 和我母亲。所以，当然，我们必须在博物馆书店花尽可能多的时间，因为她们俩都喜欢好的博物馆书店。
And I saw this book, Algorithms, and I thought, hey, we have a podcast on algorithms. Maybe I should pick this up. And it had on the cover, I don't know if you can see, the algorithm for GCD. And so I thought, OK, maybe this is interesting. But I figured picking this up not at a tech conference or something, I figured that this book was going to be something that was meant for more of a mass audience. And that is in fact the case. I think it's meant to explain to people who maybe don't have as much of a CS background or who aren't programmers what algorithms are. I think it's very structured towards our current age. The chapters are,
我看到了这本书《算法》，我想，嘿，我们有一个关于算法的播客。也许我应该买下它。封面上，我不知道你能不能看到，有 GCD（最大公约数）的算法。所以我想，好吧，也许这很有趣。但我认为在科技会议之外买这本书，我以为这本书是面向大众读者的。事实确实如此。我认为它是为了向那些可能没有太多计算机科学背景或不是程序员的人解释什么是算法。我认为它非常符合我们当前的时代。章节是，
chapter one is what is an algorithm, chapter two is graphs, then chapter three is searching, chapter four is sorting, chapter five is page rank, and chapter six is deep learning. So very, very topical. And it's interesting because the first chapter like handles like talks about the idea that we're now in the algorithmic age, that we're past the computer age. Computers are not taken for granted and it's all about the algorithmic age, that we're past the computer age. Computers are not taken for granted and it's all about the algorithm. And it talks about this idea that people are starting to treat the algorithms like they're a higher power. You know, you talk about like, oh, well, the algorithm decided this, like it's some magical thing. And I feel like that does kind of reflect
第一章是什么是算法，第二章是图，第三章是搜索，第四章是排序，第五章是网页排名，第六章是深度学习。所以非常非常切题。有趣的是，第一章讨论了我们现在处于算法时代，我们已经超越了计算机时代。计算机不再被视为理所当然，一切都与算法有关。它讨论了人们开始像对待某种更高力量一样对待算法。你知道，你谈论说，“哦，好吧，算法决定了这一点，”就像它是什么神奇的东西一样。我觉得这确实反映了
how some folks view technology these days. But it's interesting because it's both approachable, I think, to anyone, but also dives pretty deep into some pretty advanced topics. And I certainly think you need some background in math to be able to read this book and not be lost. But in the chapter one on what is an algorithm, I came across two interesting things. The first, and this is a quiz for you, I guess, Connor, do you know the origin of the word algorithm? Vaguely, yeah. I'm not going to know the exact origin, but it's from the Middle East.
如今一些人看待技术的方式。但有趣的是，我认为它既平易近人，又深入探讨了一些相当高级的主题。我当然认为你需要一些数学背景才能阅读这本书而不至于迷失。但在关于什么是算法的第一章中，我遇到了两件有趣的事情。第一件，这是给你的一个小测验，我想，Connor，你知道算法（algorithm）这个词的起源吗？模糊地知道，是的。我不知道确切的起源，但它来自中东。
If I had to guess, we're going to go and say Persian. You are correct. It comes from the name of Muhammad Ibn Musa al-Kawazim. Al-Ashima. Do you know the name of the guy that Algorithm was named after? Yeah, it's a Persian guy. It's a Karazmi or something like that. She said the same thing I said. Yeah, it's a Persian guy. It's a car resume or something. She said the same thing I said.
如果我必须猜的话，我会说是波斯语。你是对的。它来自穆罕默德·伊本·穆萨·花拉子米（Muhammad Ibn Musa al-Khwarizmi）的名字。Al-Khwarizmi。你知道算法是以谁的名字命名的吗？是的，是个波斯人。是花拉子米（Al-Khwarizmi）之类的名字。她说得和我一样。是的，是个波斯人。是花拉子米之类的。她说得和我一样。
Yeah, he's a Persian guy. So she didn't know the name either, which means let's go. And my fiance is like a history buff. She listened to, I want to say, all of that history podcast, correct? Yeah, but that doesn't make you a history buff. It does. I also took informal courses. All right.
是的，他是个波斯人。所以她也不知道名字，这意味着我们走吧。我的未婚妻是个历史迷。她听了，我想说，所有的历史播客，对吧？是的，但这并不能让你成为历史迷。确实是。我还修了非正式课程。好吧。
We'll find you another history question later. Get ready. His name is hard to say. His name is hard to say. She says she does actually know it. Oh, it is. It's hard to say.
我们稍后再给你找个历史问题。准备好。他的名字很难读。他的名字很难读。她说她确实知道。哦，是的。确实很难读。
I just tried to pronounce it and I'm sure I did it very poorly, so I'm not going to try it again. But anyways, this dude, Al-Khawazimi,
我刚才试着读了一下，我相信我读得很糟糕，所以我不会再试了。但无论如何，这个家伙，花拉子米，
Al-Khawazimi, we're going to go with that. This dude was circa like 780 to 850 Persian scholar. Worked in fields of mathematics, astronomy, geography. The term algebra comes from the Arabic title of his most influential work. And the translation of this title is pretty great, which is the Compendus Book on Calculation by Completion and Balancing. And I just think that's a great book name. And I hope it's as good in the original Arabic as it is in the translation. And his name was Latinized to Algorismos. And then that in combination with the Greek word for number, which is Arithmos, sort of evolved into the term algorithm. But algorithm originally just meant
花拉子米，我们就这么叫吧。这个家伙大约生活在公元 780 年到 850 年，是一位波斯学者。从事数学、天文学、地理学领域的研究。“代数”（algebra）这个词来自他最有影响力的著作的阿拉伯语标题。这个标题的翻译非常棒，即《还原与对消计算概要》。我只是觉得这是一个很棒的书名。我希望它在阿拉伯语原文中和翻译中一样好。他的名字被拉丁化为 Algorismos。然后这与希腊语中表示数字的词 Arithmos 结合，演变成了“算法”（algorithm）这个词。但算法最初只是指
like doing decimal arithmetic. And it's only in like the last 200 years or so that it's come to mean what the second thing that I found interesting about this chapter is. It's come to mean what an algorithm is. And the second interesting thing is, what is an algorithm? What would you say interesting thing is, what is an algorithm?
像做十进制算术。直到最近 200 年左右，它才有了现在的含义。我发现这一章的第二件事很有趣。它开始指代什么是算法。第二件有趣的事情是，什么是算法？你会怎么说有趣的事情是，什么是算法？
What would you say an algorithm is? What is an algorithm? It's like a set of operations, a routine procedure for calculating something. Yeah, so that's the definition that they give here. They give it as a way to do things. And it's an interesting definition here where he defines it as an algorithm is like a set of steps that you can follow with pen and paper. And they repeat that a couple times. And he sort of makes the claim, the author of this book somewhere here, that an algorithm is something that you can carry out ourselves.
你会怎么定义算法？什么是算法？它就像是一系列操作，一种用于计算某事物的常规程序。是的，这就是他们在这里给出的定义。他们将其定义为一种做事的方式。这里的定义很有趣，他将算法定义为一种可以用纸笔遵循的步骤集合。他们重复了几次。作者在书中的某个地方声称，算法是我们自己可以执行的东西。
And I'm not certain what exactly he means by that or why that's significant. Because I suppose he means something that like you can manually and just that computers can do it faster. I think it makes it's like a layman's olive branch, right? Because if you think of the first algorithms we learned, at least the ones that I consider, it's long division and long multiplication when you're in, I don't know, we'll say grade three, but times may have changed for those that are born after the millennia, the turn of the millennia. They might teach it sooner because that's what happens in the education system. So I guess it depends on where in the world you are.
我不确定他具体是什么意思，或者为什么这很重要。因为我想他的意思是你可以手动完成，而计算机可以做得更快。我认为这就像是给外行的一根橄榄枝，对吧？因为如果你想到我们学到的第一个算法，至少是我认为的那些，那是长除法和长乘法，当你还在，我不知道，我们说是三年级，但对于千禧年后出生的人来说，时代可能变了。他们可能教得更早，因为教育系统就是这样。所以我想这取决于你在世界的哪个地方。
But I distinctly remember learning, yeah, long form multiplication and long form division. And it's just like a set of operations. You multiply the first digit in the second number with everything in the first, and then you, you know, add a zero for the second line. It's just a set of instructions. And I remember too, being in math club for the like one month that existed at DP Todd secondary and Prince George, shout out to Prince George I remember at one point we learned the algorithm for hand calculating square roots and I thought that was very cool because up until that point up until that 30 minute lunch session or whatever I thought that was like a incalculable thing by hand because they didn't teach it in school like
但我清楚地记得学习，是的，长乘法和长除法。它就像是一系列操作。你用第二个数字的第一位乘以第一个数字中的所有内容，然后你，你知道，为第二行加一个零。这只是一系列指令。我也记得在 DP Todd 中学参加数学俱乐部的那个月，向 Prince George 致敬。我记得有一次我们学习了手算平方根的算法，我觉得那非常酷，因为在那之前，在那 30 分钟的午餐时间之前，我以为那是无法手算的东西，因为学校没教过，就像
you just oh you go to your calculator and you hit the square root button. But there was, there is actually like a set of steps where you converge into the, you know, square root of some number. And I thought that was fantastic that this thing that was impenetrable and only a button on a calculator, I could now do by hand and in your head if you so desired as a party trick at some point. So, I mean, I do think it's kind of, do I agree? It's something you can do by hand?
你只是哦，你走到计算器前，按下平方根按钮。但确实，确实有一套步骤，你可以收敛到某个数字的平方根。我觉得这太棒了，这个曾经深不可测、只能通过计算器按钮完成的事情，我现在可以手动完成，如果你愿意的话，甚至可以在脑子里完成，作为某种派对戏法。所以，我的意思是，我确实认为这有点，我同意吗？这是你可以手动完成的事情吗？
Not really. But I think, I looked up this series. It is the MIT Press Essential Knowledge Series. And there's a bunch of other books with the topics like deep learning, data science, and machine learning, revised and updated edition, cryptography. So I think this is kind of the academic version of your airport books. You know, the Malcolm Gladwell, bite size, catchy titles, usually half of them are self improvement, you know, atomic habits, stuff like that.
不完全是。但我认为，我查了这个系列。这是麻省理工学院出版社的“基本知识系列”。还有很多其他书，主题包括深度学习、数据科学和机器学习（修订和更新版）、密码学。所以我认为这是你的机场书籍的学术版本。你知道，马尔科姆·格拉德威尔（Malcolm Gladwell），小巧、朗朗上口的标题，通常其中一半是自我提升，你知道，原子习惯之类的东西。
This is like your science slash academic versions of those kinds of books that you're going to find, which it's unsurprising that they describe algorithms in this kind of fashion, right? They're not targeting people that work at NVIDIA. They're targeting people that might also, in the same, you know, fell swoop, pick up Atomic Habits.
这是这类书籍的科学/学术版本，他们以这种方式描述算法也就不足为奇了，对吧？他们的目标不是在 NVIDIA 工作的人。他们的目标是那些可能在同一时间，你知道，顺便买下《原子习惯》的人。
And there's got to be a little bridge from there to walk over from Atomic Habits to algorithms. I agree. I think that that is the essence of the target of this book. But so then a little later in the chapter, he says a couple of things that I resonate with. He says the only way to truly understand an algorithm is to perform it by hand. We must be able to execute the algorithm in the
从《原子习惯》到算法之间一定有一座小桥可以走过去。我同意。我认为这就是这本书的目标本质。但后来在这一章的后面，他说了一些我产生共鸣的话。他说，真正理解算法的唯一方法是手动执行它。我们必须能够以计算机执行实现它的程序相同的方式来执行算法。我发现这很有趣，因为当我实现一个算法或想出一个算法时，我通常会先把它写在纸上，我会先手动解决一些问题。通常就像，你知道，比我在计算机上实际解决的问题规模更小的问题。比如，我最近，我们在之前的剧集中谈到的求和面积表算法，或者我最近写了一个 Softmax 实现。在这两种情况下，我都做了我总是做的事情，那就是我挑选了一些琐碎的小问题规模，我在纸上以及 Excel 中进行了计算。我发现自己越来越多地使用 Excel 来做这件事。
same way the computer would execute a program that implements it. And I find this interesting because when I'm implementing an algorithm or coming up with an algorithm, I usually will first write it out by hand and I will first work through some problem by hand. Usually like, you know, in like a smaller problem than what I would actually, you know, solve on a computer. Like, I was recently, the summed area table algorithm that we talked about on previous episodes, or I recently wrote a softmax implementation. And in both cases, I did what I always do, which is I picked some trivial, small problem size, and I sort of worked out on paper and also in Excel. I find myself increasingly using Excel to do this.
我过去只是在纸和记事本上做，但 Excel 让处理这些多维问题变得更容易，你知道，我写下了我的测试问题，然后我设想了为了得到解决方案我需要采取的一系列步骤。或者在像 Softmax 这样的情况下，我可以在网上查，就像我不是在创造什么新东西。我有，你知道，代码。我把这看作是它所做之事的代码，但我想要理解它是如何实际工作的，并理解这一点，以便我可以向其他人解释，对吧？因为如果我想在演讲中使用它，那么我就需要能够
I used to just do it in paper and Notepad, but Excel makes it easier to work with these sorts of multidimensional problems where, you know, I wrote out my test problems and then I sort of imagined here's the series of steps that I would need to take to get to the solution. Or in the case of something like Softmax, I can look up online, like it's not like I'm creating some new thing. I have, you know, the code. I see this as the code of like what this does, but I want to understand like how does it actually work and to understand that so that I can explain it to other people, right? Because if I want to use it in a talk, then I need to be able
解释为什么我们要执行这个东西的每一步。所以，通过手动执行每一步并能够查看每一步，我可以培养出它是如何工作的直觉。你自己手动，或者也许你，写一些代码并在每个阶段打印出来，但你看看，这对于一个小问题是如何工作的？对我来说，这就像他所说的能够手动执行。这就是你开始尝试新问题时所做的事情吗？我不，这取决于问题的复杂性。而且我还有不得不等待我可爱的未婚妻用完微波炉并摔门的困难。她需要吃早餐，朋友们。
to explain why are we doing each step of this thing. And so, by going through and me manually doing each step and being able to look at each step, I can sort of develop the intuition for how does this thing work. yourself manually, or maybe you, you write some code and print it out at each stage, but you look at like, how does this work for some small problem? And that's sort of, to me, it's like what he's talking about of being able to execute by hand. Is that, is that what you do when you start playing around with some new problem? I don't, it depends on the complexity of the problem. And I'm also, I am also have the difficulty of just going to wait for my lovely fiance. Finish using the microwave and slamming doors. She needs to eat breakfast though, folks.
也许我就把这些都留在里面。我爱你，亲爱的。我爱你。去拿那个羊角面包。我希望，我希望我们不是在用微波炉加热羊角面包。那看起来像是某种法国美食犯罪。我的意思是，这不是什么高级羊角面包，而且它确实正在被微波炉加热。那看起来像是某种法国美食犯罪。
Maybe I'll just leave all that in there. I love you, sweetie. I love you. Get that croissant. I hope, I hope we're not microwaving a croissant though. That seems like that's some sort of French food crime. I mean, it's not a fancy croissant, and it is indeed being microwaved. That seems like it's some sort of French food crime.
我不知道。我们在法国的听众，告诉我们。魁北克。另一个法国。魁北克人。是的。告诉我们我们是否违反了某种，嗯，是的，好吧，你可以听到它，你可以听到它在发出哔哔声，我们不妨等着，因为她正要打开，嗯，有趣，有趣，有趣，有趣的事实。
I don't know. Our listeners in France, let us know. Quebec. The other France. The Quebecois. Yeah. Let us know if we violated some kind of um yeah well you can hear it you can hear it beeping we might as well just wait because she's about to open the uh fun fun fun fun fact
有趣的事实，我爸爸上周来看我们，我们谈到了家族史，我爸爸这边，我爸爸是被收养的，但他提到了我认为我知道，但没记住的事情，那就是他的亲生父亲是法裔加拿大人，这让我有四分之一的法裔加拿大血统，我会说这解释了我个性的很多方面，我对蒙特利尔的普遍热爱，以及我的许多傲慢，虽然不是你对蒙特利尔百吉饼的热爱，因为你首先是纽约百吉饼的粉丝。不，我算是一个皈依者。
fun fact my dad was visiting us last week and we were talking about family history and my dad's side my dad was adopted um but he mentioned something that I think I'd known, but hadn't remembered, which is that his biological father is a French Canadian, making me one fourth French Canadian, which I would say explains a lot about my personality, my general love for Montreal just many of my haughtiness not your love for Montreal bagels though you are first and foremost a New York bagel no I'm kind of a convert
真的吗？哇，我发到了社交媒体上，但我们在去摩洛哥之前在蒙特利尔参加了这个蒙特利尔百吉饼制作课程。这很有趣。它们是非常非常好的百吉饼。我吃了大概四个。
really wow I posted to social media but we did this Montreal bagel making class when we were up there before we went to Morocco. And it was a lot of fun. And they were very, very good bagels. I ate like four of them.
好吧。好吧，你们先听到了，朋友们。绝对不会让互联网上的任何人感到不安。纽约百吉饼的前情人 Bryce Adelstein-Lelbeck 现在已经皈依，并认为蒙特利尔百吉饼更胜一筹。我的意思是，蒙特利尔总的来说，就食物而言，你知道，是最好的。这就是为什么你去蒙特利尔是为了食物。这是真的。
All right. Well, you heard it here first, folks. Definitely not going to upset anyone on the internet. Former lover of New York bagels, Bryce Adelstein-Lelbeck, has now converted and does think that Montreal bagels are superior. I mean, Montreal in general, just for food is, you know, the best. Like that's why you go to Montreal for the food. It is true.
他们确实有 Felix and Norton 饼干。我就说到这儿，朋友们。海滨旁边的粉色卡车。下次你去那里的时候。我们去了这家餐厅，Candide，他们有一种菠菜的烹饪方式，是我吃过最好的菠菜。我不知道他们对这些菠菜叶做了什么，但我真的可以余生只吃那种菠菜。哇，你可以像大力水手一样。好吧，好吧，回到，无论如何，回到算法。问题是，我是否用纸笔记录事情？我说我遭受
They do have Felix and Norton cookies. I'll leave it at that, folks. Pink truck by the waterfront. Next time you're there. We went to this restaurant, Candide, and they had this preparation of spinach that was the best spinach i've ever had i don't know what they did to these spinach leaves but i could have literally eat nothing but that spinach for the rest of my life wow and you could be like popeye okay all right so back to anyways back back to algorithms the question was do i jot things out uh by pen and paper and i was saying that i suffer
从我第一次不得不理解或可视化一个问题以来，我已经离得太远了，我的第一个想法是，我绝对不需要去实现 std::reverse 来确信一次交换最后一个和第一个元素，并递增和递减两个指针直到它们收敛，是的，它就是这样工作的，这看起来很简单，以至于我会自动觉得，是的，这就是它的工作方式。但这是我真实的感受吗？因为我也会对我最喜欢的算法之一“泛洪填充”（flood fill）说同样的话。但我记得我第一次没有学习泛洪填充。我只是在 ICPC 大学的预选赛中自然地实现了它。
from the problem of having been so far removed from the first time that i had to understand or visualize a problem my first thought was that uh i definitely did not need to go and implement stood reverse to be convinced that swapping the last and first elements one at a time and incrementing and decrementing two pointers until they converge yeah works like that seems simple enough that I automatically would be like yeah that's how it works but is that actually how I felt because I would also say the same thing about one of my favorite algorithms, flood fill. But I remember the very first time I didn't learn a flood fill. I just organically implemented it in a qualifier for an ICPC collegiate
编程竞赛。我在西蒙菲莎大学（SFU）时，有免费披萨。它有这种图或矩阵问题，你必须从 A 点到 B 点。我不知道怎么做，但我只是想，我想如果你递归地从起点开始，然后加 1，然后如果你有一个队列，你基本上，你知道，递归地搜索每个方格的四个相邻元素，并保留一个你已经访问过的缓存，那应该可行。我不确定它是否可行，
programming contest. When I was at SFU, there was free pizza. And it had this sort of graph or matrix problem where you had to go from point A to point B. And I didn't know how to do it, but I just thought, I guess if you recursively start at your starting point and then add the number one, and then if you have some queue where you just basically, you know, recursively search the four adjacent elements from each square and you keep a cache to ones you've already visited, that should work. I wasn't convinced that it would work
因为它是一个递归解决方案，第一次实现或思考时很难理解。但后来我实现了它，它成功了。我就想，啊，我的想法成功了。所以这是一个我不确定是否可行的例子。但再一次，我没有用纸笔做这个。我只是实现了算法。然后你看看，你知道，你只是在最后输出数字矩阵，起点是 0，泛洪填充路径是递增的数字。我的意思是，有时纸和笔有帮助，但很多时候我只是在计算机上实现它。但我感觉，我不知道，这就像是 21 世纪的纸笔等价物。但是的，我不知道。
because it's a recursive solution and kind of hard to wrap your head around the first time you implement or think about it. But then I implemented it, it worked. And I was like, ah, my idea worked. So there's an example of something I wasn't sure worked. But once again, I did not do this by hand and paper. I just implemented the algorithm. Then you look at the, you know, you just output the matrix of numbers at the end of the day that is a zero for where you started and incrementing numbers for the flood fill path. My point being is that sometimes paper and pen helps, but a lot of times I just implement it on the computer. But I feel like that's, I don't know, like a 21st century equivalent of pen and paper. But yeah, I don't know.
即使在今天，我也确实像你想象的那样，更多地从纸和笔开始。我想我从职业生涯开始就一直这样做。有时它会在记事本或 Excel 中，就像我说的，但我认为我经常会在写任何代码之前，先从思考开始。我想部分原因是，我发现如果我在思考之前就开始编码，我更有可能把自己带入错误的道路，然后产生隧道视野。但给我多一点关于这个泛洪填充的背景，什么是泛洪填充问题？我的意思是，它有自己的维基百科页面，我敢肯定
I do even today like start off on pen and paper more than you might think. And I think I've done this since the beginning of my career. Sometimes it'll be like on Notepad or in excel like i said but i think i very often will start off um before i even write any code i'll start off just thinking through it um and i think part of that is that i've i've found that if i start coding before i think through it um i i'm more likely to lead myself down the wrong path and then get like tunnel vision but give me a little more background on this flood fill what is the flood fill problem? I mean it's got it's own Wikipedia page I'm sure
如果我们会在节目说明中链接它，但一旦你看到动画，是的，我正在看，它基本上只是对二维数组或矩阵的递归探索，你有一个起始位置。这个动画实际上并不好，我相信他们称之为泛洪填充，因为它是你在 Windows 画图或某些等效画图程序中点击填充按钮时使用的算法，你需要填充一个正方形，它会执行这个算法，基本上是饱和
if we will link it in the show notes but as soon as you see the animation yeah I'm looking right now it's basically just a recursive exploration of a 2d array or matrix where you have a starting position this actually animation is not great and i believe they call it flood fill because it's the algorithm when you're in windows paint or some equivalent paint program and you hit that fill button and you need to fill a square, it does this algorithm when basically saturating
一个空间。我想在那个例子中，你只是把一种像素颜色变成另一种像素颜色，它基本上从一个原点开始，然后你有四个或八个方向，取决于你被允许如何
a space and I guess in that example you're just changing one pixel color to another pixel color and it goes and basically you start at an origin point and then you have either four or eight directions depending on how you're allowed
遍历。如果你被允许对角线遍历，那是八个；如果你只被允许正交遍历，那是上下左右。你从，它通常有一个与你原始矩阵大小相同的辅助矩阵，你把所有东西都设置为零或负一之类的。然后你分配你的原点，值为零，然后你把所有你可以访问的四个正交位置放入一个队列。一旦你把那些放入队列，你就在某种 while 循环中。你从队列中弹出第一个元素，
to traverse if you're allowed to traverse diagonally uh it's eight if you're only allowed to traverse orthogonally it's up down left right and you start at uh it's usually you have a secondary matrix which is the size of your original and you set everything to uh either zero or negative one or something like that then Then you assign your origin point, the value zero, and then you put in a queue all the four orthogonal places that you can visit. And then once you're done putting those in the queue, you're in some kind of while loop. You pop off the queue, the first element,
然后你分配那个值加一。所以除了你存储在队列中的位置坐标外，第一个元素，然后你分配那个值加一。所以除了你存储在队列中的位置坐标外，你还需要分配你来自的前一个值。所以如果你从零开始，接下来的四个点都会得到值一，你只是递归地这样做，你必须确保，要么通过缓存，要么通过检查当我处于第二个点并检查我将要访问的四个正交元素时，你必须确保它们还没有被访问过。在某些算法中，你确实需要检查。如果是这样，如果你找到了一个
and then you assign that one plus the previous value. So along with the coordinates of the position that you've stored in the queue the first element and then you assign that one plus the previous value so along with the coordinates of the position that you've stored in the queue you also need to assign the previous value that you were coming from and so then if you're starting at zero the next four spots will all get the value one and you just do that recursively and you have to make sure either with a cache or by just checking when I'm now at the second point and I'm checking the four orthogonal elements that I'm going to visit, you have to make sure that they haven't already been visited. And in certain algorithms, you actually do need to check. And if so, if you found a
更短的路径，你可能需要分配一个最小值。在经典情况下，你不需要这样做，因为你知道算法的工作方式，你总是会以尽可能短的方式访问元素。然后你只是完成它。所以缓存是为了避免冗余地做这件事。是的，但我做它的方式，就像我说的，如果你把所有东西都设置为负一，你总是可以检查，确保我只探索当前值为负一的元素。
shorter path, you might need to assign a minimum value. In the classic case, you don't need to do that because you know that the way that the algorithm works, you're always going to end up visiting elements in the shortest way possible. And then you just do that to completion. So the cache is to avoid having to do it redundantly. Yeah, but the way that I would do it, like I said, if you set everything to negative one, you can always just check, make sure that I'm only exploring elements that currently their value is negative one.
然后一旦它被分配了一个正值或零（在你的原点情况下），你就知道你永远不会再访问它了。请务必在你的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And then as soon as it gets assigned a value that's positive or zero in the case of your origin, you know that you'll never visit it again. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一旦它被赋予一个正值或零值（以原点为例），你就知道你永远不会再访问它了。请务必查看你的播客应用或 ADSP the podcast.com 上的节目笔记，获取我们在今天节目中提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢今天的节目，祝你度过愉快的一天。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。